I have an 88-year-old mother who's
getting ready to run out of money um
like really run out of money uh my dad
passed away 15 years ago and he left her
the 15 acre property that that they were
living in in 2020 she had a little issu
she's been having some medical issues
she nearly burned the house down had
some issues like that so my brother and
his wife convinced her to live in a
nearby retirement home and I wasn't
included in that process she didn't want
to move but she agreed and she's been
there since uh August of 2021 and been
paying the mortgage on the house and
she's been paying for the retirement
home and that's bone rate of about
10,000 a month have you not called your
brother and just said what in the world
are you doing how does that conversation
go he wants to make sure the house is
perfect before it sells which it'll
never happen that that's one thing I've
asked you know what's going on with the
finances I'll get back to you oh there's
a plan I'll I'll tell you but I've Never
Been Told